[Music]
hey guys so today we're back at another
challenge and today we are doing this
smoothie challenge look at Alan Hey you
can forget one of these note and it will
say a number and then each other's bags
and whatever it has on it we pour it
into our cups see you have your kiss
size versus adult size yeah and then
after we're gonna blend it and we're
gonna drink our smoothie nice yeah ready
for this yeah okay I'm sure - what are
you doing this is and this is Isaac's
request why do you feel like making
yourself here it's awesome artists to be
awesome and scared at the same time
ready yeah I can rock paper scissors
whoever the choice all right rock paper
scissors
the winners number eight mmm shop all
right you ready present heavy is
basically smooth the best day for a
smoothie of milk all right my turn yeah
hey I'm just going the higher the
numbers go the better you get 1 2 3 4 5
6 8 9 10 11 12 13
ha ha people getting in no not really
alright number 13 you write for the hill
Oh about it
money uh your wife money haha alright I
get the truth how much honey
alright mucho honey that was good yeah
that's a lot of honey
good hunting pretty thick - a little
more do you think you have reaching for
Cheerios in here oh we can make honey
nut cheerios our own honey nut cheerios
you all right Manny made another thing
I'm at make it better I think I like a
pretty and it's more any better - hmm
Thank You number 12 well so there's 14
items that we're dealing with here and 7
of them are considered good items and 7
of them are considered bad item and
indeed your good item so far I don't
mind a smoothie with milk and I don't
mind a smoothie with honey that's the
default
joke in Albania or whoa you get to make
a lemon milkshake so far how much lemon
- yeah you know a lot and you're
inventing something they don't have
lemon milkshake squeezes Hey yes a lot
you can see bubbles look just Molly
lemon milk now yeah interesting
next up nine nine nine oh I'm making a
honey chocolate sauce smoothie so far oh
now this does not match magic this makes
you don't think what's the sweet type of
sauces that things I like that is we're
doing some next-level sweet taco sauce
yeah
bad can shake funny alright I'll shake
it I don't think it really does anything
though because they're sticking out
they're sticking to the core
alright like a workout only got milk
guess what I have a picnic right now and
you're not so bad though
yeah a cover over hung over I'm gonna
get it closer or bring this closer all
right there we go there's a poopoo can I
try a [ __ ] see you see what everyone
does that anyone - man I am NOT lucky
today easily and what did it Irish from
the shape of this bottle I can tell
exactly what it is
kimchi sriracha got chocolate sauce
sriracha oh no that is bad what am i
doing to myself no that's good right
yeah I'm taking two batteries sonic 5000
but I didn't get you a crazy pattern
yeah
alright let's wait to me number two
would he be back baby back oh oh all
right some babies is positive morning
sometimes Oh Rick Rick [ __ ] that was
delicious I have a totally hot car
crumble I can tell you this if we're
playing this movie challenge I think I'm
losing if we're playing the keep your
work station clean challenge I think I'm
winning
yes all right let's do this next one
number can tell you a tale or have to
heavy not do life that's quite sure what
it is
that comes in a bottle guess what it is
nope it doesn't come in a bottle
albatross
comes in one of these and what does that
and I'll raw egg Oh long time here make
legacy no shell okay okay go for it no
shells no shell know she'll lovely a
alright to recap this is what we got so
far I got an egg in the middle of a
whole bunch of sauces and then you got
this wonderful throw up but it looks
delicious
yeah same time alright so number six
please be pad Oh heavy what is it oh not
alone that definitely does not go in
there
you know what cat food dad's always wet
it's not like that plop all right
brother
alright let me open it I'm going to open
it for me okay
surprise hey are you Harley whoa peanut
butter this is going to give you
actually know why why because I have a
whole bunch of hot sauces in here right
so it's really tangy and just hardcore I
think the peanut butter kind of ground
it a little bit round it is so grounded
of the mom come on ground oh no I cannot
alike if you're genius like this with an
ink peanut butter is a nice being a
counter the spicy stuff right yeah all
right that's it
alright we have four more to go right I
got number forty dad
get on a porch I decided to be like dog
food or something yeah you keep getting
the canned stuff you know
yes move hard after the whole thing yeah
sure right pick some gin chicken juice
now poke him that looks delicious bill
even with the spam in the middle of it
out of all the things that are in there
right now what do you like what don't
you like I never kissed Sam so that's
the one thing you don't like oh why
can't you see anything you know Michael
Annett good you like the rest so you
like the milk you like the pod charging
like the pineapple chunks yeah
for me see and I sure like all these
things myself but I don't know if I like
it
all mixed together kind of freaks me out
all right here we go because what number
seven that's Heather that's have a good
one
you know it doesn't matter this is
terrible ready there we go this is for
when you're sick Pedialyte it's like
Gatorade but even crazier now good it
smells good it takes bed number three
whoo you can get yourself only thing
that was really bad technically is just
the fan so far for you how is awesome
Pop Tarts foods to milk beyond we all
know there's no one number left kick
yeah right number five what is this oh
how about this this is my smoothing that
your smoothie and then you share yeah so
they get to take boat whoa I'm smell
pretty good there we go that's them all
right women's language I already have a
stirrer I can already stir mine because
it looks disgusting I want to show them
what we got so far
all right so in your milk lemon juice
spam pop-tarts froot loop trying it
looks like most really good - Sam I
think really the only thing that doesn't
work for you there is a spam
hmm not like throw up literally smell
but uh won't happening so I'm gonna
blend it yeah
all right let's try it all right wanna
go first yeah it was like a bowl of
cereal good morning why all right so
we're going to put this thing on blades
on the inside tight okay fight pushing
down yeah of course
all right I'm going to flip it upside
down and ready so you want to line up
two things into the hole and then now
looks disgusting I'm good taste you
still see like the fruit loop
yeah yeah
[Music]
that fan goes a long way yes this is
there safely
let's see what mom looks like when you
flip it ready one two three pickle all
right so honey honey mmm look at that
drip drip and eat
all right ready go
[Music]
my channel you're going to shake it up a
little bit
oh that looks like throw-up yeah are you
ready to smell this oh hey hey it smells
like you wanted it smells like it smells
like you know when you spring out
enjoying spring rolls and it's been in
these restaurants and get that you know
the summer rolls and spring rolls or
whatever and you got that peanut butter
sauce come on Edie but it's pretty
intense
alright I'm gonna cry you're gonna cry
too bad okay the moment we've all been
waiting for word Frances put on the
weight very obviously that's what the
breakfast nearly - BAM I think I think
we should just good together
I'll take care got it you asked for this
I didn't want to do this I think you
will do this on internet a lot all my
friends are overworked and not a good
time you know this is mommy gets us for
a living here no we're just doing it for
fun cry yeah be ready
Oh God Debbie don't smell this too much
from already okay Cheers
three two one did you show up and you
just spit it out it tastes like throw-up
you want to try mine yeast and all that
for too long it tastes like literally
tastes like they're all yours okay Oh
[Music]
cheer me up if you start feeling sick
the moment comes near your mouth this
one I hear the big one Oh spicy yes so
much it just tastes like throw-up that
really Taylor grow up sorry my patient
Sam all right I don't know I just taste
one move and at the end once I came back
any taste the fruits in three two one
ah
I don't want to see it
are you okay throw up huh man is it
Oh activate vomit really fast it's done
oh great Nick all right holiday we're
gonna finish see how things were awesome
enough to finish this easy are you are
you really know these things this is
worth it all right you have the sparrow
ahead a better
you were ending the bathtub you know
that right you were wanting this one
yeah you want this one pill I'm gonna
try it again
no thank you what did you expect it
tastes like I was expecting like it
wouldn't it wouldn't taste that bad I
don't think I've ever tasted anything
worse than it really what it looked like
yeah lobster bit and then you got moving
a protein shake again even have two
consistent I can smell a [ __ ] she's
laboring and ice punch her nose and it
goes but you can't see fit right now
she's enjoyed the pudding and now she's
just sitting back one hand some help
which are converging Chris period is
like should we drink the rest of it I
think I should finish it no I'm not okay
you're the one that wanted to do this
challenge play mommy this is smoothie
challenge
please don't we're just here you doing
like a delicious really we had like not
much of a challenge and I'm glad I got
this one out I do this for a living guys
I don't want to do this again
you know and usually I'm in your
position Network I'm behind the camera
so I don't never actually do this stuff
I'm actually kind of glad I'm behind the
camera
I can't do this man to come around and
I'm going to be going back in you guys
continuous video alright
anyways that was our smoothie challenge
you okay now no we're not bodies are
liquor
right now yeah I can feel my fault like
my stomach's weight years trying to go
over alright guys thank you for watching
our smoothie challenge
leave a like below if you want you can
do this guy never this and subscribe
just in case I need to comment below if
you want any other challenges that means
request by chairs okay you're doing how
I do that
[Music]
[Music]